después de haber pasado ya por las
regiones de tipo 1 y 2 y sus de sus
definiciones probablemente podrás ya
imaginar cuáles son las regiones tipo 3
y bueno vamos a escribirlas entonces
vamos a escribir que una región región
tipo 3 éstas van a ser las regiones tipo
3 y nuevamente vamos a dar una
definición con juntista son aquellos
puntos voy a describir los r3 de región
tipo 3 es el conjunto de todos los
puntos que se encuentran en la tercera
dimensión es decir con tres coordenadas
tales que ahora vamos a definir el
dominio en las coordenadas x z es decir
x z está en cierto dominio de 3 ok y
además vamos a definir que ahora la ye
se mueve entre dos funciones está
acotado entre dos funciones digamos
entre una función h 1 de x zeta que va a
ser me va a ser déjenme ponerlo con
color blanco que va a ser menor o igual
que nuestra coordenadas y que al mismo
tiempo está va a ser menor o igual que
una función que siempre poníamos con
verde que va a ser h 2b x zeta ok
entonces ya tenemos bien definida cuál
es la región de tipo 3 es simplemente
como hemos estado mencionando una una
una en cambio de perspectiva es
simplemente ver la orientación mediante
la cual está hecha o construida nuestra
nuestra nuestra región en en tres
dimensiones entonces vamos a ver
nuevamente que ocurre con con la esfera
vamos a pintar primero una esfera
entonces ahora aquí es en donde tengo yo
a equis y hace está en este plano es en
donde debo yo definir nuestra región de
tres entonces vamos a definir la de esta
forma
y vamos a definirlo de esta forma aquí
va a estar mi región de 3
un poquito más amplio el círculo
y luego hacia abajo y aquí está este
círculo va a estar perfectamente
contenido en este plano esta va a ser
nuestra región de tres para la esfera de
tres y nuevamente quien va a ser la
parte inferior de iu pues va a ser la
parte que está detrás de esta de estados
de este círculo es toda esta parte de la
esfera
ok esta es nuestra función a h1 ok y la
parte de enfrente que es la parte
digamos que va así del esfera
qué es esta parte de aquí
estoy pintando más o menos de esta forma
ok
esta parte es nuestra parte la función h
2 que me define está la digamos el
casquete de enfrente de la esfera ok de
esta forma ya tengo mi esfera bien
construida y que podemos concluir que es
de tipo 3 vamos a poner otros ejes
para ver qué ocurre con el cilindro
entonces
vamos a tener ahora que en nuestra
región se debe encontrar en este plano
formado por los ejes x y z y va a
coincidir mucho con lo que hicimos
anteriormente que teníamos un rectángulo
en este plano entonces vamos a hacer
exactamente lo mismo vamos a tener ahora
aquí
ángulo
y este rectángulo va a definir mi región
de 3
este rectángulo es la región de 3
déjenme hacerlo un poquito más afuera
de 3 es este y ahora como hacemos que ya
se encuentra acotada por dos funciones
bueno pues eso es nuevamente igual de
fácil es exactamente análogo definimos
aquí nuestra función que nos define
digamos esta superficie
y estaré aquí y entonces ya se puede ir
moviendo a lo largo de todo esto y luego
para hacer la parte de enfrente pues
tendremos esta otra función que vamos a
llamar h 2 si espero se vea muy bien que
es lo que quiero estar haciendo digamos
estas son como las los semicírculos
- de esta forma y entonces toda esta
parte verde es lo que definimos como
nuestra función h 2 y entonces
nuevamente bueno esto es h 2 esto
también era h 2 y esto sería h
esto hace que el cilindro nuevamente
stand también sea una región de tipo 3
ahora vamos a ver qué pasa con el reloj
de arena el reloj de arena pues
nuevamente vamos a tener que nuestra
región
nuestra región que ahora definimos
simplemente sea digamos como el corte
transversal de esta forma déjenme dejen
hacerlo con otro color aunque siempre lo
hago con azul pero para poder encimar
muy bien y entonces lo que voy a definir
es este contorno
este contorno
que es ahora mi región de 3 y nuevamente
la parte posterior de mi superficie es
la función h 1 mientras que la parte de
enfrente de la función h 2 pero bueno
vamos a ver
que si por ejemplo este de aquí abajo
que también es de tipo 3 la rotamos en
esta dirección
entonces ya no es una región de tipo 3
vamos a pintarlo
pegar otros ejes muy bien
entonces si nosotros ahora tuviéramos
nuestro reloj de arena pero donde las
tapas digamos están colocadas de esta
forma
esta forma
conferencia muy bien creo que por fin me
quedo un muy buen dibujo de este reloj
de arena bueno más o menos lo intente ok
ahí lo tiene entonces de esta forma es
exactamente el mismo caso que ya
teníamos la y no la podemos mover entre
dos funciones porque por ejemplo si
tuviéramos aquí nuestra región de tres
entonces la aiea ali lo moviendo hay
lugares como por ejemplo los que están
sobre esta línea punteada que no se
pueden definir muy bien entre dos
superficies pero bueno podemos romper
esto como en el caso que como en los
casos anteriores en dos regiones que sí
son de tipo 3